I knew really was juicing I could have
stopped the fight but I didn't want to
forfeit this was the first episode that
we didn't have Luke Perry in the episode
his last episode just aired how will his
legacy continue on in Riverdale I know
you guys were so close he would text
your parents how are you feeling right
now I think more importantly his legacy
is gonna live on and the lives around
him that he worked with you know I'm
never gonna forget him and I think yeah
it's still still very fresh and I think
we're all still kind of dealing with it
so the lovely Molly Ringwald came in
Fred is now out of town will we see
Molly stick around how will Fred's
absence continue to be addressed yeah I
mean we'll we'll see we're definitely
going to you know obviously have to
address it at some point whether that's
Molly stepping in as more of an active
parent Pachi again that depends on the
availability of the actors around us you
know it will do what we can what would
you like to see from Archie moving
forward hmm I would love to see him I
don't know I'd love to see him do more
with the El Royale the boxing club as
everyone knows I love the fighting stuff
so so I hope he ends up owning the gym
and doing that for for longer yeah
lastly you had cheese the Riverdale
finale let's talk about that finale when
the fans have watched it what do you
think they're gonna be thinking the
shirts are off the muscles are out my
Consuelos got absolutely ripped I know
he's gonna be watching this as well so
congratulations the old man put me to
shame yeah it's the best episode it's
such a good one for sure I have to be
it's part of the job it doesn't matter
if I am or not leave you're wasting all
this to study business right over a safe
stable career in the arts you see so
many different characters so many
different relationships in this show
why was Griffin a role that you wanted
to step into I mean I've always wanted
to do a romantic comedy they're my
favorite movies I immediately was drawn
to the script when I read it
yeah I think Griffin's like a goofy kind
of dude I think I'm kind of like that to
eat and I love the scenes with Phoebe as
well reminds me a lot about how I have
no idea what I'm doing when I'm talking
to girls so yeah I I could relate to him
a lot and I think I just thought it was
a really cute story
[Music]